ちょうど昨日 東京十大学に参加しておりました者の一人でございます
南方仏教とですね この仏伝仏教
大乗 いわゆる大乗と言われておりますが
その違いというのをですね
長老はどのように考えていらっしゃるのか
また 私もよく勉強していないので
その違いを教えていただければありがたいと思います
よろしくお願いします
基本的には まあ南方仏教というのは
お釈迦様の説かれた教えというものを中心にして実践しているんですね
で パーリ聖典に基づいてね
それからこの後から仏教を学的な書いている本とかは読んだりはしますけど
それはもうあまり信仰するということはないんですね
お釈迦様の教えだけ 釈迦牟尼ブッダをのみを信仰して仏教を実践するのは南方仏教の特色で
大乗仏教になってくるとかなりいろんな信仰が入っているんですね
その差ですね それから基本聖典というのはパーリ聖典であって
で 紀元 1 世紀でしたっけ
その辺で作った経典というたくさんテキストがね
中国に訳されてあって
そういうのは我々は知らないし
もう後でできたもので
それは全然知らない 例えば唯馬経とかね
法華経とか華厳経とかは全く見たことがない
知らない  そのような差なんですね
基本的には それで南方仏教なんなのかというと
今日この講演で言ったような内容で
毎日の具体的なことだけすごい強調するんですね
阿弥陀様はどうでしょうかとかね
観音様はいかがでしょうかとかね
そういうふうな このちょっとした普通のは違った
そういう信仰的な話はまずないんです
ヒンドゥー教の神々には礼をしたりしますけど
それははっきりとヒンドゥー教ということを知った上で
菩薩信仰とかね 日本でよく見られますけどね
そういうのはない あとは不動明王やらね
それからお地蔵様とかね
そういうふうな信仰はないんですね
とにかくお釈迦様に説かれたパーリ聖典に基づいて人生設計するのは南方仏教の基本です
どんなところでも同じことをやっています
例えば宗派によって違いがなくて
例えばタイの人もミャンマーの人も
スリランカの人も もうほとんどやっていることは同じです
仏教として  そういうぐらいですね
ありがとうございました
前のちょうどあの方ですか
女性の方お願いします
よろしくお願いします
職場の人間関係について悩んでいるんですけれども
私は老人ホームで生活相談員という仕事をしています
スタッフの多くの方は入居されているお年寄りにとってというところで
一人一人本当に素晴らしい方々なんですけれども
そういう中でもＡという人はＢという人と踊っている方で Ｃ
という人とはＤという人と音程がなくて
先ほどお伝えでもありましたけれども
いじめをしたり 陰口を言って言ってうまくチームワークが取れないんですね
で 自分自身は本当に人と仲良くやりたいとずっと思ってやっていますから
私はそういう人たちともうまくいくんですけども
その人と人とがうまくいっていないことに関して
この方ってやろうっていうふうに声をかけても
なかなかそうはなっていかないんですね
で そういう中で自分をできる限界みたいなのを感じていて
どうしたらいいかなと思ってアドバイスをいただきたいと思います
これってね よくある問題ですからね
一人がいくら仲良くしようと頑張って
他の人々が協力しないとね
これかなり根が深い問題ですよ
だから自分だけ正しい
自分が言ったことだけやろうというね
これ心の狭さなんですね
世の中を知らないというね
だから井戸の中のカワウソというかね
そういう風な人格を持って
もう自分の意見ばっかし言い張ったりして
協調性がなくなっちゃうんですね
それでは何もうまくいかない
基本的に言うのは まあまあ
一応言えるならばね じゃあそれぞれの人が自分勝手に行動して
もう好き勝手なことをやって
悪い結果出して もうハチャメチャにするのはかっこいいことでしょうかと
なんとかして総合的に良い成果を出すことがいかがでしょうかと
だから私たちは自分のね
個人的なことは置いておいて
総合的に少し良い結果を出そうではないか
それこそ人間の能力ではないかと
だから皆様にも一人一人すごい能力がありますよと
言ってることその通りだよと
そちらで言ってあげてください
さすがそうです さすがそうですと
しかし 合わせてみると結果がむちゃくちゃになるんだから
良い結果になるように私たちは調整しましょうと
だから一人の意見は否定しないで
その一人にお願いします
あなたは この全体的なシステムが良くなるように
自分の機械を調整してくださいと
一人一人が独立した機械ですけど
コンバインマシンみたいに
だからコンバインマシンの一部一部勝手に行動しちゃって全部壊れるでしょうに
だからもう社会っていうのは
組織っていうのは一つのコンバインマシンだと
だから自分のセクションでプロでどのように全体的なシステムに貢献するべきなのかというね
だからいつでも良い結果を出すことこそ
我々の能力あることの証明であるというふうなことを教えてあげるしかないんですけど
理解してくれるかどうかわかりませんんだけど
まあ個人では悩んでるんだから
まあ人間っていうのはそうやってね
まあ井戸の中にいるような
自分の世界の範囲しか見えませんだから
まあまあどうしようもないんだと
だからまあ それには腹が立ったりとかね
そういうことはなく あの
まあ理解できる範囲でつなげてつなげていくしかないと思いますね
個人であんまり悩まない方がいいんですよ
あの人はなんだあれは
とかね この人はなんでこれは
とか そう悩んじゃうと
これ見えます 外で そうすると自分がまたダメになっちゃうんですね
まあそれでいいやと思う
という感じで 気楽にいた方がもっとより調整できるようになると思います
ありがとうございました
はい ありがとうございました
えっと そして前の女性の方
前列の方です はい 今マイクいきますので
ちょっとお待ちください
今日はありがとうございました
仏教では心の在り方ということで
全部問題をですね 見つめていくということなんですけど
あの いわゆるあのキリスト教ベースにした考え方で
よくあのチャネラーとかいう形を通してね
魂の存在とかいうふうに言ってるのがものすごく今多くあるんですが
長老様のお考えとしてはどういうふうに違うのか
私は全然わからないので
ぜひ教えていただきたいんです
ちなみに今 私は夫がですね
いわゆるツインソウルという存在を見つけて
今一緒に同居してるんですけど
私はそれをただ頑張って見ているだけなんですが
それがきっかけで 長老様のいろんな本を読ませていただくきっかけになったんですけど
魂と言われると全然ちょっとわからないので
仏教でいう心というものとどういうふうに考えたらいいのかなと思いまして
質問をさせていただきました
この魂っていうのは この人間
人間がこの原始時代から考えていた錯覚であって
いまだかつて何の証拠もないんですよ
で 人間というのは死にたくないんですね
しかし 死ぬんだから悔しいんですよ
そうすると私は死んでも魂は死なないんだぞという
ちょっとした痛いな 痛いな
飛んでいけと我々子供たちに言うでしょ
そういう感じで もう死ぬ悔しさをね
昔 そういう言葉でごまかしちゃったんですね
まあ死んでも大丈夫 天国でいるんだからとかね
これは 21世紀でまだまだ信仰しているんだからね
まあ面白いというのは面白いんですよ
まだ石器時代の思考でいるんではないかと
魂というのは変わらないものであるならば
私たちのこの体の中で
この脳の中で変わらないものは何かあるはずなんですよ
変わらないものが何かあるならば
すぐそれが見つかるんですよ
しかし 赤ちゃんの中にあったものってひと欠けらもないんですね
ただ川のように流れていくだけ
だから魂っていうのは全く現実として具体的に成り立たない
もう証拠全くないものです
その代わりに心っていうのは認識することです
目でものを見て認識する
耳で音を聞いて認識する
頭で物事を考えて認識を回転する
それはずっと変わるんですよ
例えば 見るものによって心が変わるんですよ
今はこのホールの中にいて
すぐ外を出る これから踊りがありますね
踊りが始めたら すぐまた心が変わっちゃうんですよ
そういうふうに 我々の心っていうのは
瞬間 瞬間 瞬間 変化して変化して流れるものですね
その流れを美しく 柔らかでしっかりすることが仏教は推薦するものであって
魂は永遠不滅なものであったら
魂は汚れるわけでもないし
汚れた魂は浄化することも不可能なんですよ
だから 単なる人間の あの何といいますか
希望的妄想概念ですね
あんまり引っ張らない方がいいというか
仏教はもうきれいさっぱりもう成り立たないんだと
一切は無常ですからね
魂ってのも成り立つはずもないんです
しかし 我々の心という認識っていうのは
川のように流れるんです
例えば荒川と言えばいつでも荒川なんですけど
昔から しかし 瞬間瞬間では荒川が違います
違うんだけど ただ言葉で荒川と言うんですね
荒川といって 江戸時代から荒川という名前があったんだからといって
絶対的に変わらない荒川があるのかというと
そうでないんですよ 川の川の水だけじゃなくて
もう形まで変わるんですよ
ですから まあそういうふうに
この変化の流れが 仏教はもう客観的で証明できるものですと
それ以外何も見つかりませんと
何も見つからないんだから
あるということは なんか冗談ですね
調べても調べても魂は見つからないんだから
その見つからないものが魂であるとヒンドゥー教で説明するんです
もう人を馬鹿にするんですよ
いくら研究しても調べないものがあってとか
どうやって調べない調べられないものがあると言えるんですかね
だからまあ 調べても調べても見つからないものが魂であるというヒンドゥー教的な思考もまた原始的で
あの まあ人間の何でしょうかね
文化的にずっと長い間やってきたものに対する愛着かなね
そういう愛着を捨てることが正しいんです
で 人を脅すんですね 魂論を持ってきてね
永遠な地獄に落ちるんだぞとかね
永遠という言葉すらも成り立たないしね
地獄は永遠だったら大丈夫です
何も動かないんです そちらは
死んだと同じなんです
天国は永遠だったら冗談でしょ
永遠っていうのは動かないっていうことですね
固定してカチッと止まったっていうことですからね
ということはもう最悪な状況なんです
だから変わるんだから楽しいんですよ
人生は 同時に一部の変わり方に我々は嫌なんですね
それはいい加減で 例えば若い時
子供が若くなるまでは変化するのを喜んじゃって
中年になってから嫌だこれはとか
髪の毛とか減った減ったりすると
あ もう嫌だと言ったって
もう同じスピードで変わるだけで
だからどちらでもまあ冷静で認めてみれば
人生ってのは楽しいし
永遠の天国は仏教は否定するし
永遠な地獄も否定するし
人間は行為によって天界に生まれたり
この行為の結果が生まれたら
また別なところに引っ越したりとか
生命はずっと一切の生命が川のように流れるんだっていうのが仏教的な立場なんです
他の教えはいろいろ世の中でありますけど
証拠はない 信仰ですね
で 神があれこれ作ったって言ったってもね
まあ証拠はないし 我々我々の以前
神がすべて作ったんだからね
作ってから私たちには条件を作る何なのかと
条件を作る権利はないでしょうに
頼んでないでしょ 神様
私を作ってくださいと頼むこともできんだからね
だから勝手に作ったなら勝手に捨てなさいよと
俺は気にしませんよと
それから神様は人間 キリスト教でよく言いますけどね
自由を与えたんだと だったら放っておけと
自由を与えたんだけど
神を信仰しなくちゃいけないでしょ
屁理屈なんですね 信仰するか
信仰を否定するか 無神存在になるか
人間は自由です 神様は自由を与えてくれたんだからね
自由を与えてくれて あんた間違いやと
自分の上からもいいところ
だからそんな人間作った作り話ですよ
そんなに気にすることはないんです
科学的にものことを見れば
例えば我々は原始時代から現代 IT 時代まで発展したのは
すべて人間の努力なんです
だったら人間の心を信じたらどうですかね
心にはいろんなことできるんだぞとかね
普通見れば空飛べないでしょ
人間は でも心で考えて空飛んでますから
今は飛行機なんか作ったりして
だからまあ神様っていうのは
まあ飴玉 1個も食えてないんです
我々には 飴は我々作ったんです
まあまあ たくさんの英語では本をたくさん書いてますよ
そういうもうもうまあなんかもうわけわからないことを言うなよと
もう怖いんだと 神を信じること自体で非道徳的になって
例えばイスラム教の方々は平気でテロをやっちゃうでしょうに
良い人はいますよ イスラム教でも立派な方々はいますけど
あまり教育を受けてない若者たちは平気でもう自爆テロやったり
人を殺したり あれはもう神様のためにやっているんですね
だから彼らが神様は信仰しながら神を否定する
ローマ法王様も神様は信仰しながら神を否定する人生をやっているんです
神様を真面目に信仰するならば
神様の気分によって作った世界だから
すべてを認めて すべてと調和して生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
ゴキブリを潰すんじゃないんですよ
ゴキブリも作ったのは神様だから
ゴキブリも生かしてあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからまあ そういう優しさがないんですね
神を侮辱したんだから殺してやるぞというふうな人々も
あの 原理主義者が現れるんですね
神を侮辱することができたのは
その能力を神が与えたんだから素晴らしいと思った方が正しいなのにね
だからこの屁理屈は信仰で迷信で強引に押し付けることでもやってますね
まあ一応そういうところで
仏教では魂はまあ成立できないということで
無我ということを言うんですね
我にあらずと 心っていうのは瞬間瞬間変化して変わるもの
だから心 汚れたりもするし
優れたもするし 時々日本でありますね
本当に真面目に生きてる人が突然人殺したりしますね
心ってのはそういうふうに変わるんですよ
だから我々はそうやってとんでもない方向へダブしないように
心の流れを守るんです
怒りはないように 嫉妬がないように
で みんなと優しく慈しみに基づいて心をガードするんです
なぜならば ガードしなかったらどんな変化するかわからないんです
突然 もう無差別に人を殺すこともあり得るんです
だから まあ心を守りましょうと
守るべきなのは己の心であるというのがブッダの教えなんです
はい どうもありがとうございます
はい ありがとうございました
他はいかがですか はい
はい もうちょっと手を挙げていただけますか
今日は参加させていただきます
どうもありがとうございました
私は長老の著書をこの半年間ぐらい
半年ぐらい前から読み始めましてですね
数冊読ませていただいたんですけれども
非常にお分かりやすい解説なんですが
一つですね デンユー草休さんと対談されている著書があったと思うんですけども
その中で確かは般若心経の中の一節だったかもしれませんけども
色即是空 空即是色というところで
長老が少しそれについてご意見を書かれたと思うんですけども
そこについてもう少し詳しく説明していただけたらありがたいですけども
それと今日は般若心経についてちょっとちょっと批判的なことをおっしゃっていたので
そのことについてもちょっと説明いただけたらありがたいです
それについて ちょっと宝島会社から強引に頼まれて
嫌々で本一つ出しましたので
あの 明確に書いていると思いますよ
般若心経は間違いという大胆なタイトルで
だって小さな本なんですね
すぐ読めます それから私の話だからね
だいたい小学生にわかるようにというレベルで書いてます
だから内容はちょっと難しいかもしれませんだけどね
うーん それも宗教を批判する意味ではなくて
単なる自由思想家として般若心経を見るとどうなるのかという目で見て書いて
色即是色 色即是空であるならば
空っていうのは全体的な真理で
色っていうのは全体から一部であって
だから空即是色っていうのは絶対言ってはならんことで
私は冗談で言うのはリンゴは果物である
したがって果物とはリンゴであるっていうのは言うなよと
これはもうちょっとうかつで
ちょっともう物事を真剣に考えていない人が書いたものなんですよ
だから A イコール B であるならば
B イコール A は正しいんですが
いつでもそういうわけじゃないんです
だからまあ色イコール空じゃないんです
なぜならば 私たちの仏教でも空という概念はないわけじゃないんです
もっと明確に もっといろんな角度から空を説明しますよ
40種類の態度 態度から空を説明する
テーラワーダでは で 大乗仏教はどれぐらい態度を取っているかさっぱりわからないし
私は龍樹の本は研究していたんだから
龍樹の空は知ってます
だから単なる信仰で色即是空
空即是色と なんだらかんだでなんだらかんだで
言いやすいし 短いしね
便利な教典だからね 大乗仏教の信仰入ってるんですが
それで空という偉大なる真理を語りながら
最後に回サンフリーステップで間違うんですよ
だから私は作者がちょっと勉強した方がいいんじゃないかという般若心経を書いた人がね
思いますよ で ファーストステップは色即是空
空即是色というところはもう完璧な間違いで
もうどうしようもないんですね
それから現象として我々を見るべきものは
四聖諦やら八正道やら因果法則やら十二因縁やら
それはもうゆえに もうもうもうもうもうともうに飛んじゃうんですね
ないんだそうと で 何言うのかっていうところは
そこは間違いなんですね
まあ私は空であったっても
現実として自分という自覚はあるんだから
それどうするべきかという説明をするべきところなんです
が それはやらないんです
それで 3番目にステップで
聖大名なんとかなんとかで
これこそ偉大なる呪文であるというと
わけのわからない呪文に飛び込んじゃうんですよ
その呪文はサンスクリット語で見ると冗談なんですよ
日本語でどうかわかりませんだけど
ガテーガテーパーラガテーパーラサンガテーボーディスワーハっていうのはサンスクリット語の呪文なんです
ガテーガテーっていうのは行ってしまった
行ってしまったとかね
あっちへ行ってしまったと
というボディはボディボダ
悟りのこと ボディスワーハっていうのは呪文を終われる時の使うただの言葉で意味がありません
それ何の力もないし これはなんで偉大なる呪文として唱えなさいというトンデモないことに人を導くのかと
苦はすごい偉大なる哲学であるならば
それでいいでしょうに
だからまあ三か所で滑ってます
だから作品としてあんまり良くないと思いますけどね
まあそういうことは私は言うのは客観的に見て
人が信仰することを信仰する経典
聖典にガチャガチャ言う権利は私にはありません
聖書は客観的に批判できますが
まあそれはまあ それで別に信仰する人は信仰してするのは
それはそれで我々はかなり柔軟性を持ってますからね
何とも思わないです 今日も佐藤さんが私に私をからかったんですけど
私の部屋に入ってきたら
あの電気の紐があるんですね
紐の最後に飾りとして小さな小さく作ってる般若心経があるんです
あ 先生のところに般若心経あるんだぞとかね
佐藤さん笑っちゃったんで
私はその時言ったのは
このあるお坊さんが 我々も知っている
よく我々に協力してくれるお坊さんがこういうことを作りましたよと言って
このお守りみたいなものを私にくれたんですね
私はまあ それはその人が作ったものですから
もう大事にそこで飾っておいただけなんですけど
私は般若心経認めないんだからって
それはゴミ箱にポイと捨てるぞってこともしませんし
信仰もしていないし テーラワーダ仏教はパーリ経典にある経典だけブッダの教えだと認めているんだから
まあ般若心経っていうのは随分後で作った作品ですから
私たちにとってはテーラワーダというスタンスでは
もう中身は良ければ認めるということで
中身が悪ければさようならと
だから大乗仏教を経典否定するかというと否定しないんです
中身にすごいことあるならば
それはもう大事に使う
あまり中身が良くないところは否定するという自由な立場をとってます
とにかくできれば本を
申し訳ないんですけど
自分の本を宣伝して 誰かから借りて読んでもいいんです
小さな本 それ読んで勉強してください
はい ありがとうございました
じゃあ今度はこちらの方
どうもいろいろとありがとうございます
数ヶ月  三ヶ月ぐらい前に母親を亡くしました
九十二歳でした で まあ九州の田舎で亡くなったもんですから
臨終に間に合いませんでしたけど
駆けつけて送迎いたしましたが
あと子供としての生き方
あるいは母親亡き母親に対するの思い
どういう風にしたらいいのか
不明のところを 教えていただきたいと思います
まあお年でしたからね
別によく頑張って人生を完了して
子供たちを育って やるべきことをやって
もう死ぬべき時は亡くなられたということで
まあ落ち着いた方がまずいいと思いますね
悲しむことはとんでもないことで
母を思うことは まあ子供としては立派なことで
まあ私たちテーラワーダ仏教ではね
まあ日々良いことをして
日々でもよろしいし たまたまでもよろしいし
何か良いことをして 母がいたならば
うちの息子はなかなかいい
いい人間に育てたもんだなというね
思えるような良いことをして
まあこういうことでお母様が幸福でおられますようにというふうに心で決めるんですね
回向するということなんですね
そういうことをして生活すれば
自分も成功成長するし
母親の 功徳にもなります
そんなところですよ あまり人は誰でも亡くなるし
お年になって亡くなることは最高ですよ
それからまあ人間っていうのはね
そんなに幸不幸になってることは決めつけられませんよ
最悪の悪人として生きていればわかりませんだけど
だいたい人間っていうのは毎日いろんな責任があって
自我があっても もうもうそんなことを言っている場合じゃないんですよ
特にお母様たちっていうのはね
もう自分のことを置いておいても
必死で家族のために頑張るんですよ
お父様たちも同じでしょうに
もう朝から晩まで仕事をして
仕事をして それで家族を育って
子供を育てて 社会の責任も果たして
もう必死で生きてるんですよ
それすごく立派なんですよ
だから自我が本来はあるんだけど
もうそんなこと言ってる場合じゃないんですよ
俺が今日は疲れたんだから
会社に行きたくないんだよって気持ちはあるんだけど
行かなくちゃいけないんだから行くんですよ
そういうふうに我々は自我と戦って
この平和な社会を築いてますよ
それだけでもお釈迦様が言うのは
君たちは何のことなく天国に行きますよと
いとも簡単に それだけでも十分だと
天国に行くということは
もう何のことなく簡単というのは仏教の立場なんです
しかし まともな人間として生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
銀行強盗をやったり 会社に行かないで
仕事もしないで 親の財産を食い荒らして
それでもう全部なくなったりとかね
もう麻薬を取ったりとか
こういうだらしない社会に迷惑
母親から見ても もう産まなかった方がよかったというふうに思われる人間だったら
もうわかりませんよ 将来は
でもそういう人っていうのは
もう 1万人に一人もないぐらいでしょうに
だったら皆様 そんな心配しないでください
将来について 大体まともな社会人として生きてるでしょうに
大丈夫です それで天国に行けますよ
喜んだ方がいいんです
だからしかし 自分の母親
父親のために回向した方が良いんです
回向するのは何か良いことをして
この功徳がお母様に 先祖様方に行きます
届きますようにと念じるだけ
あまり儀式何もないんです
はい 以上です  はい ありがとうございました
だいぶ残り時間少なくなってまいりましたけど
先ほど確か手挙げてたんじゃないかなんですけど
こんばんは 大乗仏教と小乗仏教の大きな違いという点で
私自体思っていることは
大乗仏教ではどんなに努力してもブッダにはなれないということで
小乗仏教というのはゴータマシダラですか
彼が説いた法によって誰もがブッダになれるという教えを通して実践してブッダになるということだと思うんですけれども
その長老が見る限りで
どなたかブッダのレベルまで行ったとか
精神レベルに達した方がいたとか
そういう普通の人ではなんか違うような
精神レベルに達された方がいたかどうか
ちょっとお尋ねしたいです
はい  2回に分けて答えました
同じ質問をお釈迦様に出されたことはありますよ
お釈迦様の教えを聞いて
あなた言うことはすごいことやと
信じられないんだと もし一人でもいるならば
あなた言う通りに実践して悟りに達した人を一人でもいるならば
私はびっくりしますよと言ったら
お釈迦様が私の出家した比丘たち男の中でね
一人というか  10人というか
100人というか  500人というか
もっといるんだよと それから尼さんの中でも
もう五百人でももっともっと千人単位でいるんだよと
在家の男性も女性もいくらでもいるんだよと
一人のところじゃないんだとお釈迦様の答えなんです
それからも まあそれほどはいないかもしれませんだけど
実践すればもう二 三週間でもうかなり仏道の智慧の世界には入ります
で これはもうすごい確実なことなんです
以上です  はい ありがとうございました
一応時間の関係でですね
次の質問最後にさせていただきたいと思いますけど
どなたかありましたらどうぞ A
さんですね はい じゃあ左の方の方
今日はご講演どうもありがとうございます
一つお伺いしたいんですが
私の母が献体をしたいと
今そういう希望があるんですね
母は鍼灸師なんですけれども
自分が勉強をする時に
大学病院でどなたか別の方の献体を勉強で拝見して
で その時に自分もその体をいずれは医学に貢献したいということで
そういうふうな希望を持っています
で その場合に 宗教から見た献体というのを
長老様はどういうふうにお考えかということをちょっとお伺いしたいと思います
とてもいいことです とても良い行為です
お母様の希望を叶うようにしてあげてください
決して悪いことじゃないんです
素晴らしいんです この捨てて燃やす
この物体はね 人々の幸福のためになってほしいというね
この無執着の心っていうのはすっごい功徳です
だからまあ子供から見ればね
なんかちょっと我慢できないところはありますよ
そこはもうもう偉大なる母親ということで
すごい気持ちを亡くなられた時は
それは子供たちの責任だからね
ちゃんとその希望を叶うようにしてあげてください
決して悪いことではありません
はい ありがとうございました
一応予定の時間になりましたので
また二十分間休憩取りたいと思います
次は五時二十五分からになります
じゃあどうもありがとうございます
[applause]